everybody looks at their dad at least
once like oh tell me to take out the
trash again
i thought he'd hit that age that every
man hits where they look at their dad
that first time and they think oh beat
the [ __ ] out of this dude
there were multiple times i looked at
him and i was like i'm gonna do it right
now so i'm just gonna start [ __ ]
swing so we're walking outside i'm
tightening up my shoelaces i'm like oh
it's [ __ ] on okay here we go
and i'm planning on just poking him in
the neck once really hard to slow him
down and [ __ ] father of the year now i
grew up with three older brothers we all
wrestled or fought my dad at least once
growing up but i remember when my oldest
brother the first time he decided he was
gonna
fight my dad this is one of my favorite
stories ever of my grandfather so me and
my other two brothers are in my room
we're all under the age of 10 i'm
probably like six my oldest brother's
probably 16. and he walks into the room
super serious
i'm fighting dad today
and i'm sick so i'm like
you fighting dad
that's right about dad you guys got my
back [ __ ] yeah you got your back
we got your back you know what he sounds
like
in space jam it's the monstars when
they're smaller a little slim
and they're little squirts and yeah i
got you back yeah yeah you guys ready
for some new rules i'm like yeah i
bought some new rules he goes what do
you want i'm like i want to eat cereal
for dinner he's like you got it i'm like
[ __ ] that dude i can't i'm here
i can't oh he was wrapping us up i
thought there was gonna be a regime
change everybody i needed to be on the
right side of that [ __ ] i was grabbing
pictures of my dad off the wall like
[Music]
revolution we get outside my dad's on
the patio and he's smoking a cigar just
sitting down the o.g gangster my brother
walks out and he goes we're fighting
today old man my dad stands up and he
goes
okay
if you walk up to somebody and they're
calm as a cucumber this man was smoking
a cigar on the patio and probably
drinking a whiskey and he calmly put it
down and got up and said okay
you're gonna lose that fight my dad's
confidence
should have been a bit of a red flag for
my brother dude didn't even take the
cigar out of his [ __ ] mouth
he knew he wasn't getting hit my brother
goes let me tell you something and
before he could get another word
out of his [ __ ] mouth
my dad
kicked him in the nuts so hard
and he's fell on the ground right
and my dad walks up to him and goes you
know you shouldn't talk when you fight
right and walked in the house like a
[ __ ] gangster i guarantee you nobody
in that house tried to fight him ever
again you grow up going nah man see i'm
angry at dad but i'm never going to get
angry enough to where i want to get
kicked in the nuts on the patio and we
all walk past them like yeah you
shouldn't talk when you're fighting me
well i'm not hanging outside with a
loser i'm going inside the winner like
i'm not stupid you know
but he did try to fight me so i'm
walking into the kitchen he's walking
out and he leans his shoulder into me
did you just lean your shoulder into me
maybe you should watch where you're
going he knows that if i lean my
shoulder into him i'm gonna hurt him
because he's brittle are you starting to
fight with me uh yeah not that it's
gonna be much of a fight
and i was like all right man front lawn
right now let's go and he goes no no not
not now like three weeks who are you
[ __ ] rocky what do you mean three
weeks i need to have the motivation i
need to have the theme song playing i
needed to research some moves like i had
to get my game plan down although now
looking back at it i could have just
danced around him in circles for three
minutes and we would have been good so i
called my dad on the phone we all fought
you right he goes yeah
and i said i seem to remember you being
a little more violent than you needed to
be
and he said no yeah you remember
correctly
and i said why why why why because
savage mode that's why because tom wolf
doesn't give a
listen man he wants to win right i said
yeah he said you
have to win you have to win because if
you don't win the power changes at your
house and then you try telling him to
take out the trash tomorrow he's gonna
slap you in the face and be like you
take the trash out [ __ ] don't make me
[ __ ] you up again
and then he said something by the way
that i will never forget
even if somebody ends up calling the
police
you have to win i wouldn't have gone
into this had i known he had a
conversation with grandpa before i had
just been like oh i'm bound out he gave
you advice i don't want to know where
and or be a part of so toodles i'm not a
violent dude my dad was more adept at
that and now i did have three older
brothers so i am really good at mental
torture
so i was like that's kind of where i'll
lean on so i hang up the phone and i
turn around and my wife is there and she
looks right at me she goes
are you fighting jacob
and i said no no i'm not gonna fight him
it's gonna be something we're gonna do
something in the front lawn but it's not
gonna be like a fight
and she said why why don't you just tell
him that you're the grown-up and he's
the kid
and that's it he does what you say and
i'm like nah
i said that's not gonna work it would
have worked but you know who's too
stubborn to take that for an answer
and she said why i said i'm not sure if
you were there but he basically slapped
me in the face with his dick in the
kitchen like
a little over the top not at all what
happened there's only one response
she goes i don't like it i said i'm not
saying it's the right response i'm just
saying it's the only one that i know you
know
and she said i don't think this is a
good idea and then i maybe got a little
too cocky
and i said
i'll let you know when i have a bad idea
and she was like oh okay like that right
there is a foreshadow he's gonna lose so
i know i gotta start torturing my son
right
i call my brother on the phone because
i'm like you guys tortured me endlessly
what should i do and he said what do you
mean
all you talked about growing up was like
i wish i had a little brother so i could
do to him which you guys did to me he
goes now is your chance
nobody gets to go back and do that and i
was like you're right
this is quite an opportunity
and he said yeah man do you want me to
send you over the list what list he goes
oh the list of things that we had that
we used to do to you
that's evil like they had a written list
of [ __ ] that they would do to him and
new ideas and i said
why do you still have the list
and he was like you never know do you
know
and i'm looking at it and he said just
remember the most important thing is to
start small and go up from there
so this all started on a sunday now
listen he wants three weeks i don't want
to give him a full three weeks i want to
get him so mad that he wants to fight at
the end of the week because that's the
only chance i have of beating him right
so my brother's like start slow like
okay so sunday night when my son asleep
and i took all of his underwear out of
his drawer
and i replaced it with panties with the
days of the week on
so when he woke up the next morning i'm
cooking breakfast and i hear hey these
are in my underwear
these aren't my underwear
and i just yelled back hey just put your
mondays on sunshine and come on out for
some breakfast
i've never actually admitted this before
but
i did try on those wednesdays not bad
and he was like i'm gonna fight you so
hard
and i was like don't say that don't say
that i'm gonna fight you was one of the
things that i wanted to say and then i'm
gonna punch you so hard was the next
thing that wanted to come out and so the
overall that came out was i'm gonna
fight you so hard oh i'm gonna fight you
so hard
[Music]
a co-op for air different
[Music]
is
[Music]